hi i'm david i'm ryan and we're going to
review the amazing spider-man 2 trailer
that came out today yes did you like the
first in the reboot series i did i think
mark webb did a great job i think andrew
garfield is a great actor for spider-man
i i like the feel of the ultimate marvel
universe that these movies have been
bringing in and not so much the silver
age which is what the other book toby
mcguire movies were doing david i'll
tell you what i'm right there with you
cool so like not to bury not to opposite
bury the lead here upside down pyramid i
love this trailer it's amazing i like it
we start with the spider he's got his
new suit now yeah and the new suit by
the way i absolutely adore yeah it looks
like a comic book coming to life the
color palette in this trailer is
different than the first movie it's a
little brighter and more saturated
this movie was shot in 35 millimeter
instead of uh red epic which was what
the last one we were shot on
now we got spider-man saving new york
that's a pretty cool shot
and then we set a graveyard
a little bit okay let's just go there
for a second so now we can see that's
the rhino well that this right here is
the rhino and look that's paul
that's the top of paul giamatti's head
yeah so he sits he sits inside this suit
now the rhino in the 1960s spider-man is
just this russian mercenary he puts on
this
uh kind of like a rhino looking suit and
he bashes through walls well not a rhino
looking suit he's called the rhino it's
a rhino suit yeah so he's like a rhino
horn on his head it's a gray suit he's
really big and strong and he just breaks
walls and robs banks it's it's a pretty
pretty simple character yeah he's not a
lot of moving gears yeah and here he's
in this sort of avatar mech suit it's
kind of inspired by the uh ultimate
marvel
well rhino is more of a robot yeah
they're trying to be a little more
realistic with this one with giant mech
robots
and that's there's about the green
goblin that's the green goblin it's
green it's a goblin ai
and then we got i don't think we need to
explain it anymore
it's green goblin it's the green goblin
who i didn't know was going to be in
this movie the escort building looking
like it's been repaired from the first
movie yes when the lizard destroyed a
bunch of it dude so there's our first
shots of electro we we've been hearing a
lot about
um
strange that's something
we've been hearing a lot about jamie
foxx and also that time square sequence
which i think that they showed at sony
uh to a few press people also there was
a trailer shown at comic con that this
is not the same trailer and i saw a
bootleg of it and that trailer was
completely about electro and this is
more about basically the sinister six as
we're gonna see yeah there's a lot of
there's something we can stop there
here's a matrix shot
if you look up here follow the daily
bugle on tumblr whoa we're entering this
we're entering 2013 spider-man guys this
is like this is not your spider-man if
we're following the release date 2014.
2014.
so
matrix shot it's been long enough that
that's cool again i'm going to be honest
so
one of the highlights of the first film
was the chemistry between emma stone and
andrew garfield
yeah let's go back so harry osborne is
now not james franco but dane dehaan who
is an amazing actor i think a really
incredible actor yeah placed beyond the
pines he was amazing and we're hoping
that there won't be any scenes with
harry osborne eating pie in this film or
the um what was it like they're making
an omelette together
um we're hoping that neither kiersten
nuns nor james franco touched this movie
with a 10-foot pole
um
so there's some cool tech
so they're spying on peter parker i
think they know he knows he got bit by
spider at osborne i mean
that's also we saw pictures from this
sequence the that's paul giamatti
driving that tree yeah there's an
armored truck yeah the
i imagine it's probably early in the
film
um maybe like a cold opening
i really hope there's a good cold open
to this so they're they're digging more
into the uh secretive live computer
parker as well which they hinted more in
the trailers for the first film and then
really followed through on campbell
scott plays richard parker as father
which really excites me because i that's
an actor that i absolutely love also i
love that this is like this is the first
thing we've seen we never saw this in
toby maguire movies where the uh the
father is a character yeah now this
phrase let's talk about this okay we got
the vulture on the left and we got dr
octopus on the right now this is but
should be a post-credit scene right like
this should be such a reveal i imagine
now we can assume that this is norman
osborne who's being played by chris
cooper who we see a better shot of later
um but the hints that the senator
sinister six could not be right
especially
they stop at the six now if you go back
to the last frame
there's there's seven oh but they very
deliberately stop i mean they know what
people are expecting here what are
behind those vaults
back to that shot
so harry osborne has something green
kind of on his neck looks like got bet
maybe or like or a hickey
yeah you ever think of that he was
making out with a green
goblin
i don't know let's keep going yeah and
then we got electric heels so that's
electro jamie foxx which is kind of a
cool little like really silly comedy
bookie thing that i'll buy it looks like
doctor
manhattan um
that electric heals are the way like he
falls into a vat of electric eels or i'm
sure it's a little more like it's polly
one can only hope
um
so there's our first shot of the glider
without peter
there's norman osborne looking not none
too good
there is the ring
yeah so this is just now we just get
into like hey guys this movie's gonna be
awesome shots
um this is bigger than you
what's interesting to me about this
trailer is that they really don't
hide anything if they show you all the
villains we go back into that there's
there's team the honest if we look at
his his uh his hair it's kind of swooped
the same way that like the green goblin
always had you know like that hat that
kind of swooped back and his face has
kind of got like a crooked nose yeah
that looks very i think that's cool it
looks very much like the ultimate green
goblin it looks like they're fighting in
some sort of like cathedral almost i
don't know what that is a solarium maybe
a solarium i don't know there's like a
glass ceiling yeah you know the famous
spider-man celebrity i believe you it
does actually look like
that there's there's a plane it's an
iron man 3 reference
we see more and more from this time
square sequence
um which is probably going to be like
the centerpiece of the film
which they probably spent so much money
on
also i
also in the comics and look if you see
like electric kind of like teleporting
around yeah which is red or electric
imagine this in 3d i wonder what i'm
wondering is there when electro
showed up in uh there was a spider-man
sorry double-sized issue in the mid-90s
where elektra showed up and spider-man
made like an electro proof suit
and i wonder if that's gonna it really
plays into peter parker's scientific
thing um you know he's a scientist i
really hope we see that one it's a
really cool suit and two it really plays
into the character in terms of what he's
capable of scientifically which is
something with this the web shooters
that they're really going into more yeah
in this one in the in sam raimi's series
you know it was like he's really smart
and and teachers seem to like him and
when raindrops keep falling in my head
is playing he does really well in school
but um i i think that they're starting
to plant the seeds for him to be a
really more yeah because he shows up
with the oz corp the um the lizards the
scientists and they sort of teach each
other together and use a lot of the like
my dad was a scientist and
in the comics the dad made venom which
is this suit that you know everyone
loves this is in the ultimate comment
yeah in the ultimate marvel um mostly
written by brian michael bendis so let's
hope they sort of bring in carnage or
venom in the third movie sort of using
the father if only because the way that
he was treated in spider-man 3 it was
yeah also the most disappointing
spider-man 3 it was an alien and in the
comics it's been changed yeah i mean in
the original comics i think todd
mcfarlane um did this venom saga in the
80s it was it was the symbiote suit
brought down from the moon but
you know david i couldn't be i'm i'm
super excited i'm excited that's my only
concern is can they have six villains
can have this like we all it is the
spider-man with all superman or
superhero movies too many villains
equals really bad usually like think of
any movie where there's just tons of
villains and they just want to make toys
that's not a good thing but this could
work yeah and i like the direction mark
webb was headed with the first movie
i there's no reason
that i should be worried no reason at
all so yeah so let us know what you
think of the amazing spider-man 2
trailer and also like you excited for
this franchise as as david and i are and
until next time i'm ryan and i'm david
thank you for watching
you